[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show
some interesting stories for you one has
to do with mexico we talked about the
outgoing president of Mexico on the
Regular Show now we're going to talk
about the incoming Mexican president the
Mexican government has a Boeing 787
which is sort of like the Mexican Air
Force one it's the presidential aircraft
that Mexico acquired back in 2012 for
more than 218 million dollars they are
now selling it it's only been a few days
since the new Mexican president obrador
took office but he is already putting
into action his campaign promise of
selling the presidential plane and using
the proceeds to help poor communities in
Mexico he hasn't done that part yet but
they're starting to get rid of the plane
and that he will be flying commercial he
said I will not get on the presidential
plane I would be embarrassed my face
would be filled with shame if I board
such a luxurious plane in a country with
so much poverty and he is flying
commercial he is often subject to delays
Pat as happens in commercial aviation I
say good for him although I do question
only as devil's advocate would he be
more effective in fighting poverty if he
didn't have the cumulative effect of
years of flight delays and going through
security like I'm just I'm not saying I
agree or disagree with what he's doing I
think it's a fantastic show of and I
don't mean show facetiously it's a
fantastic putting his money where his
mouth is that he really does care about
poverty and it doesn't make sense for
him to have a private Boeing 787 when so
many people are living in poverty I
think that's all great but if we're
talking over the course of his
presidential term hundreds of hours of
delays and additional travel time as a
result of this might he not do more to
help poverty if he had the private plane
oh yeah I don't doubt that he will get
less work done but it's important to him
as a politician to be perceived as a man
of the people and I think he's doing a
good job at that he's also only going to
take 40% of the presidential salary and
he's disbanding the Mexican equivalent
of the Secret Service which I find
incredibly interesting because as
president of the country you do have a
target on your back you're gonna have
some haters and everyone just about can
recognize you so I don't even know if
that's a smart move I don't think it's
something that I would do if I was
president I I agree I probably wouldn't
and I do find it interesting III find
Mexico to be such a fascinating country
and I'm trying to get I've never been to
Mexico City I'm trying to get there
within the next year my dad is in Mexico
right now and he's actually been doing
some lecturing in some of the less
cosmopolitan parts of Mexico and you
know it's there's some tough situations
in Mexico there he described security
circumstances at some of the places he
stayed as being very tense and a lot of
care being taken to ensure that my dad
doesn't go to the wrong place so to
speak so definitely a lot of issues that
Mexico is contending with but it's just
such a fascinating country huge country
diverse culturally because of all of the
different you know you have sort of
Mexican national culture but then you
have so many subcultures within Mexico
that are fascinating I'm personally
super interested Pat and following the
presidency and and seeing what actually
happens during this term yeah I might be
going there actually in the next couple
of months and I would be looking forward
to that if it does transpire I know that
you follow South American politics quite
a bit this story actually reminded me of
the former president of Uruguay
he was like considered the people's
president he lived in some small shack
for a home and essentially he's doing
what AMLO plans to do but on steroids
you could say yeah the new Guam
President had a Volkswagen Beetle that
he continued driving as far as I recall
at least kind of like as a daily driver
while he was president Mujica was the
there he's no longer in office very
interesting guy very interesting guy
let's talk about former NFL quarterback
Brett Favre for a little bit he has now
apologized claiming that he was tricked
tricked into recording an anti-semitic
video for an organization claiming to
represent veterans the one group called
the handsome truth and another called
the [ __ ] defense league both known
anti-semitic groups prayed Brett Favre
500 bucks to read a script that included
coded language and dog whistles and when
it became clear that he had no idea what
he was saying and it was grossly
anti-semitic he has now apologized so
let me tell you what the script was
first of all does Brett Favre need to be
doing this for 500 bucks it would be
really weird to me to learn that he
needs the 500 bucks I don't know his
financial situation the paragraph he
read for 500 bucks was Brett Favre here
with a shout out to the handsome truth
and the gdl boys you guys are patriots
in my eyes so keep waking them up and
don't let the small get you down keep
fighting too and don't ever forget the
USS Liberty and the men and women who
died on that day god bless and take care
so first of all this entire waking them
up thing that's a term used by the
anti-semites and by the men's rights and
right wing extremist groups to talk
about being read pilled
read pilled awakenings politically that
includes
a whole bunch of white men are really
the oppressed people type of stuff and a
lot of other things don't let the small
get you down the small is an
anti-semitic reference to yarmulkes the
head coverings or kippas as they are
also known head coverings that more
religious jews wear the USS liberty is a
dog whistle for anti-semites that was a
research ship that was attacked by
Israel during the six-day war in 1967 it
was mistaken by Israeli forces for an
Egyptian ship so Brett Favre claiming
that he was tricked
others apparently also tricked by these
groups
and he put out a statement saying
basically that he does these all the
time that he's done like 50 of these
that some of them matched service dogs
to veterans who have PTSD all sorts of
other stuff and later he learned that
the request actually was from an
anti-semitic group and that he is
sickened by these groups and he's
against what they do at what they're
doing and what they stand for I believe
the guy Pat because I don't think that
he would I have no reason to think that
even if Brett Farve was anti-semitic and
I don't believe I have no reason to
think that he is I think he's smart
enough that he wouldn't say I'm gonna do
this but then if there's a problem I'll
claim I didn't know anything about it I
think he just genuinely got tricked you
could say he didn't do enough due
diligence that would be a fair criticism
but I think that's about as far as we
can go
I think you give him the full
exoneration that was my one critique
though like maybe he didn't do enough
due diligence but the problem is the
language is so incredibly coated and if
you're not into these alt-right
anti-semitic tropes you may just not
understand them like if I was to read
this I probably wouldn't pick up on it
either the one thing I would question is
don't let the small get you down like I
have no idea what that means so I would
probably look into that he could do a
quick Google search on what the USS
Liberty is but it just sounds like a
message in support of the troops more
than anything else and he's done about
50 of these messages on kansan I think
it's called so he's I think just in the
routine and didn't expect anything to
come out of this don't you think though
that goi'm Defense League should have
maybe been a red flag and maybe Google
that one and see what that is Joey I'm
defense league
yeah well oh but it's GDL though so I
don't they do shorten it yeah I don't
know exactly how it was presented to him
it's not candidates cameo by the way
just correcting myself their cameo okay
thank you so anyway I don't think that I
think if anything he brett favre is
guilty of ignorance and not doing enough
research but i have no reason to think
that brett favre is an anti-semite a lot
of people will be surprised to hear me
say that because they say i call
everybody an anti-semite but of course I
don't I didn't call Brett Favre one
that's for sure okay
speaking of anti
semitism the white nationalist who drove
a car into the crowd of counter
protesters at that horrible
Charlottesville Virginia rally last year
began sobbing and whimpering after his
arrest when police told him he killed
someone according to video that was
played at his trial yesterday before the
rally he had sent his mom an image of
Adolf Hitler that was evidence presented
during the hearing and then also this
video taken within minutes of the end of
the mayhem at that rally shows him
saying that he acted in self-defense but
also sobbing and crying as a result of
being told that he killed someone what
do you think about this Pat I mean
should that video of him crying be a
mitigating factor in terms of guilt or
innocence or for sentencing or is it
listen he acted in a way that was
willfully a neglectful and aggressive by
starting to run people over it's a form
of vehicular it is vehicular homicide
the fact that later he cried doesn't
really change too much about what the
crime was that was committed here maybe
maybe maybe so because if you're trying
to distinguish distinguish between
premeditated murder like first-degree
murder and he the moment murder second
degree I think how he initially reacts
when he finds out that the person was
killed is relevant because I have to
imagine that if he planned something
like this he wouldn't feel automatically
remorseful for what he did because
that's what he set out to do whereas if
it's manslaughter or heat of the moment
he could feel that regret right off the
bat so I do think there's some relevance
to that piece of information well what
if it was premeditated and he still
cried right I mean that's the thing
where we don't know we know what actions
were taken we don't know someone's
mindset always in terms of premeditation
and we don't know the mindset that goes
into someone sobbing all we really know
is what happened so I don't know I'm
kind of mixed about it but I understand
that his defense attorneys are doing the
best job they can
and he's entitled to the best possible
defense of course I don't I don't even
suggest denying any of that I'm just
sort of wondering if I was a juror what
the impact would be on me of that video
I think there are three possibilities
for why he's crying there one is that he
realizes the error of his ways and that
white nationalism is the deplorable
viewpoint to have another one would be
that he wanted to hurt people like he
wanted to make sure that these counter
protesters got theirs but he didn't want
to kill anyone I mean then come on
that's just way too far and then the
third would be that you know he just has
this selfish reaction to it like he
understands that because he killed
someone he's likely gonna spend the rest
of his life behind bars and you don't
know exactly which one of those three it
is and you can draw different
conclusions from all three of those well
there's a fourth one which is that these
these were sobs of joy and that hasn't
that that I think you should also be
mentioning Pat in your in your list of
possibilities there we're gonna be
following the trial we'll see what
ultimately happens I do want to hear
from you about it thank you to all of
our new members thanks to our new
patrons really appreciate everybody's
support we are starting to wind down
2018 and we have really big things
planned for next year and I'll be able
to tell you about some of those
hopefully before the end of the month
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]